stop skipping breakfast or you should
skip breakfast we've all heard that
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day but some actors and athletes
like Terry Crews are adamant about not
eating breakfast so who's right is
breakfast good or bad I stopped eating
breakfast for two weeks to find out I
can't eat anything before 12:00 when I
have lunch for as long as I can remember
I've had breakfast every single morning
but I also know a lot of people who
don't eat breakfast and that works great
for them to be honest I don't think it's
gonna go very well because I'll be awake
from 6:00 all the way till noon a full
six hours without eating a single thing
it's a lot different than what I'm used
to and it might be really hard
especially at first half of you are
probably typing a comment about how you
never eat breakfast but making a change
to your daily routine isn't easy and I
wanted to find out if my life was better
or worse without breakfast today was my
first day not eating breakfast and I've
got to say it went pretty well I was
surprised to find out that when I woke
up I wasn't that hungry I made coffee
made lunch for the day and still wasn't
feeling like I needed breakfast I stayed
pretty busy she was already noon and I
had barely craved any food at all I
don't want to jinx it but I'm feeling
pretty optimistic for the week so it's
Wednesday it's been three days of no
breakfast and I've got to say it's
getting a little bit harder so yeah it
wasn't going well I feel like every day
around 10:30 or 11:00 I get really
hungry my stomach starts to growl and I
start seeing or smelling food around the
office that other people have and it's a
lot more challenging than when I first
wake up and I know it's like okay that's
not actually a problem but if you're
someone who's trying to diet trying to
eat less trying to snack less it can be
really challenging when you have a lot
of options around the office that can be
really quick or convenient
I've actually amassed kind of a large
store snacks at my desk all the stuff I
can't eat
after lunch and then I'm like oh you
can't even eat that and it just kind of
sits there and stares back at me if you
can make it through the week but I am a
little worried about the weekend waking
up at 6 a.m. and not eating until 12:00
is such a long time why do I need
breakfast when so many people can live
without it what's actually going on here
I spoke with dr. Peterson a scientist at
the University of Alabama to find out so
what I think this happens in breakfast
skipping and why it's so confusing is
there's actually not one way to
necessarily skip breakfast you actually
have better blood sugar control in the
morning and you digest your food a
little faster in the morning as well as
you burn very slightly more calories
when you eat in the morning so all this
evidence kind of points towards the
morning as being optimal for eating so
if the morning is the optimal time for
eating is skipping breakfast hurting me
was this whole challenge pointless on
the flip side we've also learned over
the past decade that it looks like
having extended bouts of fasting is good
for your health
what's really interesting is that you
have hunger hormones and these hunger
hormones adapt to whatever you usually
do or to your habits what this means in
the short term if you don't normally
skip breakfast and then you suddenly
skip breakfast you have to overcome that
inertia of changing your hunger hormone
patterns because your hunger hormone
says ok well you usually eat breakfast
and now you're gonna skip it so I'm
gonna make you very hungry anytime you
have a regular eating pattern and change
that regardless of what eating pattern
you're on you will have an initial
barrier where it's quite difficult in
the beginning and then over time you
adapt maybe if my new routine is worse
than my old one it's been about a week
and a half and I gotta say it's getting
easier I thought now having breakfast on
the weekend was gonna be a nightmare but
it was actually a lot easier because I
woke up later and didn't have as much
time between waking up and noon as I do
on the work day but I do still miss
breakfast I just enjoy breakfast and
eating something in the morning even if
I'm not super hungry I think I'll still
miss that aspect the whole thing has
really made me wonder how much breakfast
matter
it kind of feels like breakfast was just
the routine it was just my norm so
that's what I liked and that's what I
was used to after a week and a half of
not eating breakfast it started to seem
like I was finally getting used to my
new routine maybe I could turn into
someone who never eats breakfast but I
wouldn't count on it
it's finally Friday and tomorrow I can
have breakfast once again after two
weeks I've realized that I can go
without eating breakfast and still
survive but I miss breakfast not eating
before 12:00 was really tough especially
with all the food around the office and
it definitely brought down my mood
throughout the day but I never really
felt a big change in my productivity or
even my energy levels before or after
lunch and my weight stayed pretty much
the same breakfast isn't bad for you but
it's also not essential you should do
what fits best for your dietary needs
and your routine I no longer feel
helpless without breakfast and I'm able
to create a routine that fits my
schedule and my daily needs before I
started this challenge I love breakfast
and I thought I needed it to start my
day now I don't really feel that way
I still like breakfast and will continue
to eat it but I don't feel that reliance
on it like I used to have so it turns
out you can skip breakfast
but dr. Peterson pointed out that
instead of skipping breakfast it's
better to shorten the window of time for
meals each day two broad types of meal
timing approaches that we found to be
beneficial one is the daily intermittent
fasting approach where you're eating in
a narrow time period and it looks like
probably eating in the middle of the day
say from 10 a.m. to 6 p.m. is also good
for your health there's a lot of
evidence that even if you can't change
the timing of you know breakfast lunch
and dinner if you at least make your
largest meals earlier the you know
breakfast and/or lunch that you can
still get a lot of benefits from that
some people love eating breakfast and
good for them but don't let someone try
and tell you that you're throwing the
day away if you skip breakfast the most
important meal of the day depends on
who's eating it
now this is how breakfast should be